4つ日課ピーナッツバター子ですね
完璧
英語ですべらべらべら彼らが一つ分かったことがあるんだ
なんで日本の湯チューバー商品紹介特におかしいですね
なんでお菓子の僧院数回が多いかっていったら
もう明らかですよぼく何か思ってたんですよなんで日本ばっかりなんかそういう印象回
多いんかなと思ってたんですけど
結論的に言いますを振っか切れずに来て思ったのは
日本のお菓子はすごいですハンパないですよ
これを市乳って書いてあって買ったんですけど
本当に何か新商品っていうのがまず見つけにくくてまず食玩なんてないし
お菓子のせい商品も多分あんまり出てない9発てそれに比べると日本のお菓子は本当に
すごいと思いますよ
だって毎週新商品のパステルじゃないですか
食玩とかおもちゃ付きのお菓子とか
なんか凄いなになり文味とかすごいてて切りずはねうまりお菓子に力を入れてないと
いうか
だけで納得しましたなんで日本の湯中場所儀仗隊が大きく悪かっていったら
間違いなく日本のお菓子がすごいからなんですよ
よってなんかその議員総会ばっかりとか
なんかは
なんかそういう爽快批判してる人とかよくいるんですけどちょっと違うと思いますねー
何て言えばいいんだろこのわかってほしいんだ
この投げ位
日本の文化の2商品紹介は日本の文化です
日本のお菓子はすごいんですよなんですよ
日本の歌手
もちろん何でも僕は商品紹介いいと思いますよ
が衣服に思い知らせてやりたいです予約し商品飛んでにつけたのがこのスニッカーズの
ピーナツバターですといい
アッシュ材ですよ全市場に見つからない2つが2つ
2つ入っ2つますね
日本日本こっちに来て日本すごいと思った
ミシンとぜんざいこう紹介したいと思うかしないし
これでもたが日本で見たことないと思いますよだった親友って書いてあってもイギリス
でに打って語った多分ないように思ってます
me
ほ
これは前
まあ断面見せた汚いとか言える b ナッツが入ってて
甘いですよ
夢はこれはね本当に夢はこれ多分 amazon で買えるんですよ
でもないんだだけに戦の経験がないからしか買えないんだよ
ぜひどうしても食べたいという人はは
アマゾンで買ってください本当に美味しい本当に美味しいんですよ本当においしいのと
刷毛は一番言いたかったのは
その商品紹介についてですよ日本のお菓子はすごいですよ
たく世界トップレベルだという
僕わかったに考えてるんで出来れば日本に帰りたいです
じゃあ